one of the films I was talking about one
on one of my trips to
your and I wanted to finish the story
about uh you know all the things that
you
may put in your head about what you want
to
do you know those who have never
been can you
imagine
finally making the decision
you've arranged to go one of your
friends who is also an
aroka you go to a you're going to enjoy
all the things that those sense he had
built and as well as training with
the what we would consider the best in
the world oh sense's top students out
Sensei who was left the caretaker's job
of running the
dojo until he passed away
himself and then it reverted back to the
Rish
family where now it's being run and run
very nicely had a lot of money spent on
it made it very nice and done it all up
and so refer fish what what
required throughout the whole
premises I haven't seen it since then
but the pictures that I have seen show
it very
beautifully now from
uh the dojo area it's if you can imagine
two separate plots of
land and they're divided
by excuse me they're divided by a small
T mccadam
road that goes straight past
the the dojo entrance s of sense's house
section and where Sensei built a three
story building for his son he
hero um for when the dojo was no longer
being run by the cyto
family and then they would be able to
have their own Dojo sense his house that
would obviously go to
hio and everything that goes with it the
dojo is on the top floor of the three
story building the restaurant is below
it's not a restaurant any longer it was
only a restaurant for a very short
period of time before it closed
um but he hero got remarried and moved
to another part of the village where he
built his dojo that also looks very
beautiful never been there but looks
very beautiful anyhow we're in Japan and
um I've got many stories that I may
share with you if time allows one
day but the one thing I've always been
very personally interested is the
spiritual side of our senses
art but kept a lot of it to myself
because uh in the days that I was
training it was a very
physical time and really because we
could never seem to get the techniques
right and even when you thought you had
them you'd find that there'd be somebody
who's
immovable you know or better than you
and so you're forever striving to
improve your technical
side on a personal note you know when
I'm in living in my own head and living
at back in my own country
and you know really living in your head
I'll say more than on the map
time the map time was devoted to getting
down to the
technical you were so busy working with
your partner these were the days where
you you hardly said two words you might
say can I do it again but the real
training was you wasn't allowed to do it
again when I was taught in the UK we
would be allowed to do it four times
each and then you change Partners sorry
change the partner your partner would
change and do the technique and it went
on like this it was more of an aerobic
workout so if you had time uh to talk
you'd use it by getting your breath
back and you'd say very very in an hour
and a half class you would say very few
words you might have a a small laugh or
a quick can I do it again if it was
really bothering you most of the time
you would just train and be
thrown down up you get throw them down
and that's how it would
go you'd sit in CER while the Sensei
taught the next technique or give you a
talk and there was no set time how long
it would
be but you know finally I'm off to
I I've said before that cyto Sensi said
to me at one of the seminars around the
world he awarded me up to Fourth Down
and he said Tony for your fifth Dan
you've never been to a you've got to
come to aama if you want me to give you
it so please come and uh we arranged
that I would be
going in
1994 where he would test
me so I arrive it's all very strict and
you have certain rules that you have to
abide by and you're told all them by the
the dashes that are already living there
you're told what to do what cloths to
use this cloth with two dots is for this
this cloth with one dots for that so
it's a real wake up call and being in my
40s you don't really like being told
what to do you've you've run a business
you brought up a family uh you've made
decisions since you was an adult
you don't like 19 year olds telling you
what to do and especially in a sort of a
a manner that's
disrespectful so you just think to
yourself okay well I'm only here for 3
weeks uh this was my first visit I'm
only for three weeks I can put up with
that and um not retaliate or get upset
about it just get on with it do what
you've come for get your 50 down enjoy s
of sense's
company but then it goes on to I'm
actually in O sense's
Doo I'm looking at o sense's belongings
I'm looking at ens his books enormous
amount of
books they're all laying all over the
places as if the shelves have collapsed
and nobody's been allowed
to repair the shelves and put put them
back up there's a small kitchen that's
never used it's called the chesai choco
it's a small kitchen is next to O
sense's uh there's a wall but next to O
sense's living room and where he would
also sleep with his wife on the
tatami the tatami sound permanently in
in that room then there's a small
Corridor he had a very very small but
westernized toil it in a sort of a
triangular piece it looks like it was
almost like an add-on and somebody my
size would I don't think ever get in
there anyhow that and then the doorway
comes through into this um chesai Shaka
do kitchen and um there's a stain still
sink
there I didn't see any cooking
facilities just more to Tammy and this
is where the students would put all
their bags their clothing and this is
where we would sleep in the
afternoons and in August when I went it
it's definitely the wrong month too it's
hot humid and um four hours of training
a
day very very demanding and I thought I
was super fit and prepared myself but uh
I don't think I was prepared quite for
what I received anyhow she'll never
forget it uh a wonderful
experience but one of the things I I
asked was across the road where the
ginger is it was all boarded up there's
this big like poles they call it the
gate you may have seen it on some of the
pictures it's like Telegraph poles
making into forming a like a tea
frame and when you look through that
you'll see the the actual Ginger the the
building where they hold
ceremonies and the doo would come after
her centy passed but since he built it
all he built
several items around the ginger that
fenced off now um that he would I
suppose class as monuments to the gods I
don't know what they are really they're
just wooden
structures again they can be seen in
photographs so I just ask like uh I'm
gone all that way I'd like to see into
the ginger please no you can't do that
it's only for special
ceremonies and it's not uh for you to go
there and me being
me uh I've pretty much tried to do what
I want to do on my life I hope that's
not an arrogant statement but uh you
know why shouldn't you try to do your
best and try to get what you want out of
life as long as it's not going to hurt
anybody in the
process and i' travel all these many
many hours to get to
Yama and I just wanted to see what it
was like right inside the
ginger so I didn't even tell my friend
that my plan was
to wait for the right time and then I
would go
across and uh look in the
ginger I can't remember if in
1994 if I had a mobile phone or not I
don't think I
did any I know I didn't have one and I
didn't have a torch
either may have been
my you know shortcomings because I
certainly needed one from what I'm about
to tell
you so most nights after training they'd
be training at 1 hour for 1 hour and
then most nights after
training uh I can't remember the time so
I'm going to guess it was 7 to 8 at
night
but if any of the top teachers Japanese
teachers wanted to come and drink in the
Main Kitchen what
was uh adjacent to the dojo itself not
the small kitchen I was talking about of
our
senses it's not a very interesting
building at all sort of a tin
building that holds perhaps up up to 20
students I'm guessing in again but there
was quite a few while I was there and
sensey would cyto Sensei would come on
certain lunch times and he would uh eat
with us and and talk tell us stories and
that was wonderful and sometimes he'd
even cook he used to love cooking green
chilies that
we not want to eat cuz they were a
little burnt and blow your head off any
he used to laugh a lot when he saw us
not been able to eat them so freely as
he
did so in the evenings um they would
come and because it was a busy time of
the
year and when people leave they have to
leave uh a gift for the showman and this
was normally in the uh you would leave
an envelope perhaps with some
money um but you you've not normally
leave bottles of
Saki and and you'd never believe the
massive size of these bottles I mean
like they look like 2 or three
liter in
size of either show you or sake I don't
know if one's a rice one and one's a
potato but they both taste like sake to
me so you would leave these they'd be a
a nice wrapping and you'd put them in
front of the showman and you may have
seen photos of the I Dojo with with all
these bottles in front of them different
times and what we would do as students
um they would be left there for a period
of time and then they would be removed
and taken over to the the main kitchen
where all the students
would dine um and then uh one of this
top sire would come
and they would decide that you know
everybody would drink and you'd open
these bottles and drink whatever the
drink was there and until they decided
that they wanted to stagger home or
however they would
leave that would be the time we would
stop and go to bed and some nights you'd
pray they'd go early but they never
did but one night out of the 3
weeks uh
nobody came we sat there we had
our
meal and everybody was so worn out they
all said they were going to bed and I
pretended I was going to bed but of
course you'd get up perhaps to go to the
toilet whenever so I had a plan I
thought I'm going to go over to the
ginger so not telling anyone about it
even my friend
off I went across the road and it was so
pitch black it was unbelievably dark but
I knew and there was enough light to see
where I was going in the daytime I'd
spotted a a side entrance door to the
ginger so I made my way up to the
door opened it but
inside was so dark I don't know if got
electricity there but anyhow it was so
dark I couldn't
see I'd worked out over the period of
the days because you rake in front of
the ginger the the sort of gravel dirts
whatever it is Sandy dirt each morning
you would you would rake it all the
dashes would rake it in a line until you
got to the road when you'd finished and
then we train weapons on it always seems
a bit strange to me that you're you're
starting a fresh and you leave it all
untiy rather than um break it perhaps
again at the end of the period leaving
it
tidy I digress okay
so I I decided that I felt down open in
the door I felt down I could feel that
it it was to tamy there so I thought
right take shoes off leave them there
and aliko to the center of
the uh
Ginger and I had to guess roughly where
the center would be but of course I knew
where the showman part would be because
I knew when I come in the door entrance
that the showman would be to my
right so not wanting anybody to catch me
whether they would or not and that time
of night I closed the door as I come
in and it was so black I can remember
now that when it's that black that you
cannot even see your hand if you put it
up in front of your
face
and that didn't deter me because I just
wanted to be in O
sense's uh spiritual room
so a sheo to the center as I say and I
sat there and all of a sudden it was as
if this uh
horrendous noise
started and all I can tell you is
whether I have a vivid imagination
perhaps I do but it sounded like all the
gods
were either cross with me or they were
just telling me what you're doing in
here or they were showing me what I'd
like to think about even if it's not
true that
they knew that I was there and they
wanted to make me realize that there is
life after death and they wanted to show
me the power of their
presence The Sounds were coming in all
directions into my
ears and I never heard so many sounds
before and I've tried to replicate them
on one of the films
but not with great success but they were
s of
oh high pitched low pitch deep but not
just one or two but many of these
different
sounds and all I could remember doing
was I don't know if I closed my eyes or
not it was that dark it didn't matter
but I remember sort of gripping the
tatani with my knees in my Batts the
best I could because all I could think
was hang on because it was so powerful
it was as if they were going to put me
like in a washing machine I was going to
become hled through the air in all
different directions the voices were so
turbulent
that the only thing I could think of and
it must have been a natural reaction was
to cling on to the tatami and hope that
they wouldn't take me somewhere or do
something with
me um perhaps that was one of the few
times in life where I actually
feared the unknown
I came after it calmed down it did calm
down the sounds and it I'm sure it
wasn't there only for a few perhaps
seconds it might have been there longer
but I don't know but I I just hung on
and hung on and when it all went still
again I slowly choed backwards to the
door or where I guess the door was I
remember trying to search for it the
the the get out
latch placed my trainers on blue and
white trainers I had at the time placed
my trainers
on and went
back and went to
sleep
and so now I'm sharing this with the
world
because I think that it's worth telling
the story
I've had lots of different
dojos I've had since uh the
then I had a
dojo in a big dojo in UK I had another
quite reasonable one in on a Greek
island calonia that would hold about 25
six people
and and now I've just built this one
what holds 8 to 10 at
maximum
people so I didn't really want to build
this last one because I couldn't see any
point but then I come up with an idea
that it would be nice to teach small
groups and very detailed and personal
iida now when I finished this I've got
the tatami down it all look nice all
nice and new I got a spare piece of
tatami put it down so it didn't
impregnate it I got my meditation St out
put my meditation store down in front of
the
shaman sat on it closed my
eyes and I didn't have all the lights on
that I got now but I closed my
eyes and all
those gods and Spirits or whatever they
were were were here in this very dojo
and I've never ever had it in the other
two
dojos so I'd like to conclude this uh
story
now by telling you
that perhaps is dojo is meant and
perhaps that's what the spirits are
telling me to pass on what I I can about
the spiritual aspects that I've found
throughout my iido career rather than
keeping them personally to myself and
everybody thinking I'm a lunatic or
weird or odd perhaps all iido are odd
and weird um but to share it with others
so so to me this was an indication that
I should um now
seek a teaching more about the spiritual
aspect
that one should try to prosper
in and then they can do the technical
with other
teachers and as well as I still do
technical but really it's more about
talking about the spiritual side of what
I think we should do and um hopefully
those gods and spirits that were with me
in 94 in
I and again when I've heard them here
and they were the exact same ones so why
they would have come I have no idea I
didn't think of it I didn't bring them
on why would I done 94 to
2023 it's
um wasn't in my intention whatsoever
but I bought the the house the C Amo and
all the equipment when I was there in
'94 I had the as I said in the other
film I had Sensei Hendricks kind enough
to do a special Shinto ceremony to bless
it and to hopefully ask the spirits if
they would reside in the house and help
me with my iido in the future and
hopefully that's what's happened
and I will let you know in the afterlife
cuz obviously I won't be able to answer
that in this one thank you for your time
and I hope you've
enjoyed um the stories that I've been
telling bye for now